so
thanks james for introducing me and
thanks everyone for attending my thesis
defense today
i'm honored to defend my thesis entitled
smart tutoring through conversational
interfaces
my phd work has been about educational
technology
and it was inspired by bloom's true
sigma problem
in 1984 bloom one of the most
influential educational psychologists
found that students who were tutored by
a one one on one expert tutor
could achieve learning outcomes to
standard deviations higher
than students who are taught by
traditional classroom methods
so bloom's finding has excited many
learning scientists and educational
practitioners
however one of the major limitations of
one-on-one tutoring
is that it's too expensive to scale up
to the majority of the students
so computer-based tutoring systems have
been suggested as a promising solution
to simulate and eventually scale up
one-on-one human tutoring experiences
for decades research have been designing
and building computer-based tutoring
systems
such as the famous auto tutor as shown
on the right ear
which is an intelligent tutoring system
that teach university students
subjects such as computer literacy and
physics
however the prior work has their
limitations
first most of the existing computer
tutors
are designed as formal study tools in
traditional classroom settings
in real life people especially adults
usually learn outside of school
instructions there hasn't been much
study
on how to design engaging tutoring
software for people to use in their free
time
second although people have started to
try to make teaching personalized
using techniques such as reinforcement
learning
so far no prior work has demonstrated an
adaptive way
of tutoring that can be applied at scale
third human tutors usually learn from
tutoring students
in fact the tutors in the studies
conducted by bloom
were highly trained expert tutors the
computer-based tutors we have today
have limited self-improvement
capabilities they cannot monitor
students learning trajectories
and learning outcomes to adjust during
tactics
to become more effective because of all
these limitations of prior computer
tutoring work
as well summarized in his literature
review work in 2011
tutoring researchers should retain
bloom's challenge
and strive to develop computer tutors
that are two standard deviation
divisions more effective than no
tutoring
moreover when we look at current
commercial solutions
even these solutions are limited they
primarily consist of learning activities
with limited interactivity such as
multiple choice questions
review and flip flash cards and listen
repeat practices
these learning applications are
typically not very engaging
and as a result their effectiveness
typically relies on learners own desire
to learn
and we know that there does exist a need
to improve current education
for both child learning and adult
learning here are some supporting
statistics
71 of americans think stem education is
better in other places
according to department of education
every year
1.2 million students drop out of school
and lastly more than 80 of learning
happens in informal learning
environments
hence the overarching goal of my
dissertation work is to create effective
and engaging computer-based tutoring
systems
that can be used in informal learning
settings for both children
and adults
how to design such tutoring systems
we need to understand what are major
factors separating performance of
human tutors from computer tutors
prior researchers found that their
feedback and scaffolding
feedback refers to timely feedback when
students make a mistake
or become stuck scaffolding is an
educational term
it refers to providing guided prompts to
encourage
students to move progressively towards
stronger understanding of a problem
we know that human one-on-one tutors
provide feedback in sky folding
through natural language conversations
with students
what if computer tutors or chatbots did
this too
can the interaction between computer
tutors and students
enable better learning as well
chapels are computer programs that
stimulate conversations with humans
and they can be promising for informal
learning for these reasons
first natural language processing
algorithms are becoming
increasingly more sophisticated nowadays
and ready to be applied to education
second conversational user interfaces
are usually highly engaging
third according to the well established
icap framework
student learning usually increases as we
move from passive learning
to active learning to constructive
learning
and to interactive learning this
indicates that an interactive
conversational ui
might substantially increase student
learning
chapels have other benefits when applied
to education
according to many previous research
studies
first chapter learning is a social
endeavor
and chatbots can hold casual
conversations with students
and promote social interactions the
promoted social interactions
as a result can promote students
question asking
that might need to improve engagement
and learning
second chatbots can deliver instructions
for feedback
out of order based on students current
understanding and
reactions hence making teaching more
adaptive
third researchers have shown that
chatbots can help you
students report and that helps enhance
students learning efforts
and performance in mathematics
fourth chatbots can create a student's
sense of approval
and autonomy when students receive
feedback
fifth because natural language dialogues
are highly engaging
they allow learners to actively
construct knowledge when formulating
responses
based on all these financial benefits of
chatbots and
the limitations of prior computer
children work
here i present my thesis statement
conversation-based tutoring systems
that leverage new ai techniques to
provide adaptive feedback
can engage students more motivate them
to spend more time using the tutor
and improve student learning when
compared to the current learning systems
i'm going to divide the rest of my
presentation into four parts
by presenting four different
conversation-based tutoring systems
the first two systems are for adults to
learn factual knowledge
and english as a second language the
next two systems are for children to
learn mathematics
the reason why i developed these four
different systems
is that i want to show the efficacy of
conversation-based tutoring systems
across different age groups and for
different subject
areas
now i'm going to start with the first
system quiz belt
a dialogue-based adaptive learning
system for adults to learn factual
knowledge
this work was conducted in collaboration
with my collaborators at stanford
and published ike 19.
in real life we often need to memorize a
lot of factual knowledge
such as terms in science vocabulary and
all kinds of rules
and people usually take time to memorize
these things outside of a classroom
setting
however current electronic tools such as
flashcard apps
are passive and boring so i want to
provide better automated ways
to help learners learn factual knowledge
in a more engaging way
therefore i build quiz thought a
dialogue based adaptive learning system
for people to memorize factual knowledge
on facebook messenger
here are the key components of my quiz
bot app
it has an interactive chat interface as
shown on the right
with an animated avatar which can
provide positive feedback
quiz spell supports a mix of typing and
button-based interactions
to provide students with abilities to
type their answers using keyboard
and asks for hints and explanations
using touchscreen buttons
i use a smooth inverse frequency shift
algorithm
to convert to convert students typed
answers to sentence embeddings
so that we can compare them with correct
answers
i also use an adaptive question
sequencing algorithm
to present items in adaptive way based
on each student's learning trajectory
to maximize the learning outcomes for
students
in quiz thought i teach people factual
knowledge in three areas
advanced english vocabulary science and
safety rules
i chose these subjects because they are
the importance of
areas of sexual knowledge that people
usually learn in their daily lives
i hypothesize that this new
conversational ai based interaction
can make factual knowledge learning more
engaging and effective
to further evaluate quiz bot i also
built a flashcard learning app
which is based on popular flashcard apps
today
such as quizlet and studyblue
i carefully control the variables
between the two systems
quiz file and flash card app share the
same adaptive item sequencing algorithm
same factual question pool and sim hints
and explanations
the only independent variable between
the two systems here
is the interface quizbot has an
interactive conversational interface
and the flashcard app has a cap and flip
interface
i want to answer these research
questions through user studies
first how engaging is quiz felt to
learners in comparison to the
traditional flashcard app
second when learners practice a fixed
number of items
which app is more effective quick spot
where the flashcard app
next given voluntary usage which system
is more effective here's how i designed
my user study procedure
students first came in to take a
pre-test to measure their
prior knowledge then they started to use
both apps for five days under different
study specifications
on the last day students first took a
field in the blank post test to measure
their recall accuracy
followed by a multiple choice post test
to measure their recognition accuracy
under the user study procedure i
described i ran two user studies
that each had an important difference in
the conditions
with two separate groups of participants
the first study was a visiting subject
study where we fixed number of items
practiced
aiming to measure the effectiveness of
the two apps
the second study was an observation
study where people used both apps
voluntarily
for any amount of time they wanted every
day
this study was designed to measure
people's engagement with the two apps
we recruited 70 76 college students and
alumni
from 12 different u.s universities
including stanford
these students came from over 20
different majors
in the first study we had 23 female
students and
17 male students with an average age of
23.5 years old in the second study
we had 15 females 20 males and one chose
not to disclose
the average age here was 22.8 years old
now i'm going to present the results we
had from the first study
we found that giving a fixed number of
items practiced
with quiz belt people recalled ants
recognized over 20
more correct answers the difference here
was statistically significant
for both recall accuracy and recognition
accuracy
this shows that quick spot is more
effective per number of questions
practiced
in comparison to the flashcard app the
results here are immediate closed test
results
after five day learning period we also
perform
delayed post tests one week and two
months after the study
and we found that although the gap
between crispr and flashcards became
became smaller the difference between
the two was still significant
at two months afterwards therefore the
learning improvement
brought by quiz thought persisted over
time
however quick spot had its own drawback
which is it took 3.2 times more time
for people to learn with quiz about than
with a flashcard app
when practicing the same amount items
with that now i'm gonna present our
second finding
from the second study
people actually voluntarily spend 2.6
times more time with quiz bound
than with a flashcard app of their own
position
the difference here in usage time was
statistically significant
this shows that people found quizbot
more engaging
and willing to use it more than the
flashcard app
because people voluntarily spend enough
time on quiz vault
their recall performance was
significantly better
than when using the flashcard app and
their recognition performance
was similar
on scale of 1.5 i also asked people to
read quiz thought and the flashcard app
in terms of ease of use fun
effectiveness and efficiency
quizba was rated as significantly more
fun
and more effective than the flash card
app in both studies
quiz bond was rated on par with a
flashcard app in terms of ease of use
and efficiency in both studies
i also asked participants about their
preferences between the two apps
more than 68 of users in both
experiments
like crispr and more than 63 preferred
using it for casual learning
but the percentage dropped when it came
to preparation for exams
likely due to crispr's lower efficiency
to summarize i designed build and
evaluate quiz thought
a conversation based learning system for
factual knowledge learning
that incorporated some of the latest
progress in sentence embedding
and space reputation algorithms
i found that compared to the traditional
flashcard learning app
crispr helps learners recognize and
recall more than 20
more correct answers than the flashcard
app
despite taking longer to learn with quiz
about learners were much more engaged
with quiz about
and willing to spend more time
as a result this led to learners
improved
learning on recall with quiz bout when
usage was voluntary
seeing the positive results of applying
chatbots to factual knowledge learning
i now would like to shift my focus to a
different subject
language learning which is an extremely
popular subject in adult learning
and has been studied by by numerous
people
this work was conducted in collaboration
with future labs in qinghai university
in beijing
and will be published at iui this year
why is english learning such an
important area in language learning
according to the british council's
report english is currently studied by
1.5
billion people worldwide this means that
1 out of every 5 people on the planet is
an esl learner
however one-on-one tutors for language
learning
are usually inaccessible and expensive
for most people
although there exists some inexpensive
self-study resources
these resources for speaking are
primarily listed repeat based
so can we replicate the effectiveness
and engagement of quiz ball
apply what we learned for language
learning
another challenging aspect of applying
chatbots to spoken language learning
is that it requires voice-based
interactions
i conclude that speech recognition today
powered by the
neural networks is much faster and more
accurate
than traditional keyboard-based input
messes based on a study i conducted in
collaboration with baidu and the
university of washington
this indicates that speech recognition
nowadays is ready to enable more
sophisticated voice-based interactions
with that i built english spot a
language learning chapter
that converses with students
interactively on college-related topics
in english world we use automatic speech
recognition
powered by deep learning we provided
adaptive feedback based on learners
natural language inputs
we also provided hints in learner's
native language in case they needed them
now i'm going to walk through each
component of my english voice system
first we have a learning material pin
here which is comprised of two sections
vocabulary and sentence structures
designed to assist users
in completing the conversation with a
chatbot
the conversation practice pin show on
the right here
serves as a major learning window where
most of the learning actions
and interactions take place as well as
all conversations between the user
and english ball
english boss dialog bubbles indicated by
the orange boxes
consists of chatbot utterances the
chatbot also comes with the audio play
button
which is used to replace audio after
english sentences
and a translation button which
translates english sentences into
chinese
the user's dialog bubbles indicated by
the dark grey boxes here
contain the user's replies adaptive
feedback from english vault
a reference answer which can be clicked
by the user
to display the reference answer and an
audio play button
that reads a reference answer to the
user
the next section indicated by the orange
box
is a hint bar containing hints in the
user's native language
the bottom section indicated by the two
dark blue boxes here
is the operation panel where the user
records
edits and sends their replies to english
boss prompts
6a shows the first phase prompting the
user to speak out now
to record their response the speech
engine then transcribes users responses
to
text 6b shows the transcribed text
the user can click on the mic button to
continue recording
or edit the text field because speech
recognition may now be 100
accurate in fact in our user study
the speech recognition engine achieved a
94.5
accuracy
here's how the complete english bot
interface looks like on student
screen there are already two exchanges
of conversations
for example the chatbot says here you
will never believe it but my dog ate it
and then the user replies with you must
be kidding
and the feedback the student receives is
fabulous
the current dialogue here is the fifth
exchange
to compare english file to more standard
approaches
we implemented a traditional style list
and repeat interface
based on popular speaking english
learning apps in china
such as semi-english and little english
as shown here the solution repeat
interface
was designed to have the same color
scheme and ink layout as
english spell however users cannot
provide any conversational input to the
system
which is a major constraint of the
popular english learning apps nowadays
hence the only independent variable
between the two systems
is the conversational ui versus a
traditional ui
similar to quiz boss studies we
conducted two studies in two different
learning scenarios
fixed usage and free usage however
unlike crystal studies where users use
both apps at the same time
users were randomly assigned to one of
the true systems
and only used that system in their six
day learning period
so that we can trace people's spoken
english improvement improvement later
to one of the true systems
here's a user study procedure users
first took a series of pre-tests before
getting started
including a free form and a script-based
speaking test
in the fixed usage study users were
asked to complete all conversations
in one unit each day by following a
strict order from beginning to end
with no repetition this study may mimic
the use of english
in a classroom setting in the free usage
study
users were given access to one unit each
day
and allowed to complete as many or as
few conversations
in the unit as they desired this study
examines the effectiveness of
english bot in more real-world
conditions
and may better simulate the use of such
a system
outside the traditional classroom
settings such as during self-study
we recruited 56 college students with an
average age of 23.4 years old
these students came from 22 different
universities and 30 different majors
our native chinese speakers
45 of them had never been in
english-speaking countries before
and 11 had only been abroad for
short-term travel purposes only
europe's average total time in
english-speaking countries
is 1.3 months
similar to quiz boss studies we want to
answer the question about
which system is more engaging given
fixed usage which system is more
effective
and given voluntary usage which system
is more effective
now i'm gonna present our results from
the first study
first we observed that there was no
difference in user self-reported
engagement scores between the two
systems in the fixed units
in the fixed usage setting
user speaking improvements were
evaluated by speaking test with graders
the greeting was down across a according
to a grading rubric
adapted from the out speaking test
across four different metrics
fluency and coherency coherence
lexical resources grammatical range and
accuracy and pronunciation
here we found that there was no
difference in speaking english
improvement
across any of the format metrics between
the two systems
in the fixed usage setting
moreover english spell took 2.5 times
longer to practice the same amount of
the same amount of learning materials
than the traditional system
so through this first study the fixed
usage study we haven't found any
benefits of using
english of using english vowel to learn
language
now i'd like to move to our second study
the free usage study
first we found that english bought was
more engaging than the flashcard app in
the
fury usage setting according to user
self-reported engagement scores
of their own volation english spell
users spend 2.1 times more time
than the traditional system users and
the difference was statistically
significant
with a large effect size
there was also a significant improvement
in learning gains
on the script-based fluency evaluation
measure but not on the rest
this is my speculation but the results
could have to do
with the duration of our study our study
was only operated over a short time span
and we know that language learning takes
a lot of time to make progress
so this work suggests that more work
might be needed to understand how to
best create
and use interactive chatbot technology
to support
efficient and effective foreign language
learning
in both fixed usage and free usage
settings
to summarize in this work i build a
voice-based chatbot that helps college
students improve their spoken language
and conducted user studies under two
different conditions
and i found that english bot engages
students more
and motivates them to double the time
span in free usage settings
english belt also improves student
speaking fluency more
in the free usage setting however in the
fixed usage setting
english english bot achieves similar
learning and
engagement and is less efficient in
comparison to the traditional system
now i like to switch gears here and
shift my focus on different population
children designing learning solutions
for children is even more important
because children have shorter attention
spans compared to adults
and need more engaging methods so that
we can cultivate their passion for
learning
how many of us have remembered learning
math in elementary school
learning math is a really important
phase of learning for young children
for the next two systems i'd like to
explore how to design
engaging and effective children chatbots
to support
children's math learning
my systems for child learning draw
inspiration from a popular book here
called the diamond age where a young
girl receives a book
in the form of a tablet the tablet
reads a story embedding the girl
protagonist in
as a major character and through
activities and narrative
this book gives a girl a complete
education
she grows up to be an independent woman
with a personalized education
received from the smart book i developed
a learning system
around this book by first implementing a
narrative based learning system
with a wizard of oz chatbot which means
the java was controlled by human tutor
instead of being fully automated
this work was conducted in collaboration
with many collaborators and published at
idc last year
first we like to review the impacts of
narrative-based learning
narratives have both pros and cons on
learning
on the pro side they can help develop
students mental models
they can also captivate students more
and increase student immersion
when narratives are embedded in
educational games
you can also deliver better learning
outcomes
however narrative-based learning has its
own drawbacks
sometimes narratives might distract
students from learning
narrative-based learning is usually is
usually less efficient
compared to no narrative
and they might impede students recall
and
problem-solving abilities according to
some previous research
so in my project i want to first examine
the effect of narrative
on children's math learning does
narrative actually
improve engagement and effectiveness
second i want to add chatbots to
narrative-based learning
and test their combined impacts on child
learning
here are here's the interface of the
narrative-based learning system i design
and build and the key components
we i provided a narrative-based learning
experience for children on tablets
the narrative is personalized based on
the child's context
i also embedded a multi-step math
learning task
into the narrative and lastly
i provided feedback support through two
ways
one a hinge system and the other a
wizard of ours tutoring chatbot
the hinge system i implemented here can
give feedback in a linear order
this is a design used in popular
learning platforms nowadays like khan
academy
i also designed four different user
study conditions
in the first study students completed
the educational task
in the second condition condition b
students
completed the same educational learning
task but embedded in a narrative
in the third condition i added the hinge
system
and in the last system in the last
condition the hinge system was replaced
with a worth checkout
the major difference between condition c
and condition d
here is that hints came in linear orders
and students could only see them one by
one in chatbot
however the wizard could choose which
hinge they think most relevant to the
student
based on students reactions rather than
sending them to the students in a preset
order
here are the interfaces of the four
conditions
first the task-only condition
in the second condition students first
read the story
then they started to work on the same
math problem
in the third condition we provided a
hinge system
as shown on the right side of the
interface
and in the last condition we had this
interactive chat interface on the right
as i mentioned earlier the checkout was
implemented using watch technique
meaning the human tutor actually control
the checkout
here we could see that this wizard hid
in a private room
and sent messages to the kids through a
dashboard
in real time the wizard also had
real-time access
to children's facial expressions and
learning behavior
through a camera
the wizard was allowed to perform four
different types of actions
she can have a small talk with kid
encouraging the kid
providing some direct hints and lastly
checking children's understanding
for the math learning task i designed it
as a six step interactive math task
for greece three to five children the
task
involves three concepts here
multiplication
fraction and volume here i'm showing you
one of the steps we designed
step four given the measurement of
height
length and width how many chocolates are
there in the box so this question
aims to teach children measurement and
data operations and algebraic thinking
and the targeted grid levels here are
4.5 we also mapped the
question to the common core state
standards
lastly number of hints here indicated
the max number of hints
students could obtain in conditions c
and d
through the hinge system or the chatbot
to assess students learning outcomes
participants took a math quiz
right before and after their interaction
with my tablet-based app
all questions were drawn from account
academy and singapore
math books with selection guided by the
common core state standards
to limit learning effects from repeated
measures
we utilized two versions of the quiz
version a
and version b where the only difference
was that numerical values in the
problems were changed
and we counter balance a demonstration
of the true quizzes
we recruited 72 grade 3 to 5 children
to take part in the study 18 children
were randomly assigned to each of the
four systems
these 72 children were from 43 different
schools in the bay area
32 of them were in third grade 24 in
fourth grade and 16 in fifth grade
half were boys and half workers and we
equally distributed them based on their
grades and gender
across the four conditions
so how do children react to these four
systems
first we found that narrative based
learning was more engaging
than non-narrative which is consistent
with
previous literature findings then we
found
that narrative plus chatbot was also
more engaging than
no narrative what surprises here is
actually condition ce
narrative plus hand conditions we didn't
find
children um enjoy it more we're not sure
why
it's possible because the hints are not
personalized for the children
so that they have to read them in a
linear order one by one
this might add a lot of actual cognitive
flow to the children
in terms of learning improvement we
found that
kids in the narrative plus chatbot
condition
and learn more on the volume concept
than case in the control condition
again the results here that narrative
plus hint does not help with learning
surprises
us although hints and chatbots cover
same
content and information relying on
children to read the text is not an
effective way of teaching as shown here
instead delivering hints in adaptive
order
through a conversational interface is
more effective
to test retention we send out a
follow-up test to all participants
one month after their lab study i
plotted the percentage of children in
each condition
who solved each step of the virtual
learning task
as indicated by the red line here
narrative plus chatbots improve
retention
to summarize i build a narrative-based
learning system
with four different conditions and
conducted lab studies with 72 children
i found that narrative is more engaging
confirming the past leadership findings
i also found the narrative with chapel
media feedback
promotes engagement narrative with
chatbot immediate feedback
also enhances students learning and
retention
i didn't find any benefits of using a
linearly ordered hint system
this might indicate that current
learning platforms based on the popular
linear hint design
can potentially be improved
now that i have obtained positive
results from the narrative plus a word
chatbot
could we actually build a real automated
i want to see if i would get similar
results with a real chatbot rather than
a human wizard
additionally in the last study the
wizard had
real-time access to children's facial
expressions and
learning behavior so it was difficult to
conclude
how much of the effective effectiveness
came from natural language tutoring
now i'm going to present the last system
i viewed which achieved the goal of
automating the checkbox
check box and discuss what kind of
results i received
this work was recently completed with
the help of my many collaborators
the solution i adopted to build an
automated chatbot was reinforcement
learning
i used il to determine what kind of
message should be provided to students
given their natural language inputs the
ir chatbot required
zero training data and performed online
learning
the policy we used was built using the
proximal policy optimization
algorithm here's the interaction
flow between the children and the arya
chatbot children first came in and
finished the
pre-test to measure their prior
knowledge then they
started to work on the math problem in
the problem solving stage
children could send a message to the
chatbot then the chatbot will
perform action selection to select the
feedback to send back to the kid
based on if the kid found the reply
helpful or not
and if the reply was a hint or not we
send different reward signals to the
chatbot
at the end of the problem-solving stage
the kid
either quitted the task or successfully
solved the task
in either case the kid needed to
finish a post quiz and we used the
student's improvement
from postcards to pre-test as a reward
and lastly if the kid created the task
we send a big penalty to the chatbot at
the end of the interaction the chatbot
performed the update
as we know in reinforcement learning
it's important to design
the observation space action space and
reward function
now i'm going to talk about each of them
in detail in the observation space
the chatbot has access to the children's
grade
children's preschool which step of the
six-step task that
kid is currently in and how many times
the kid has failed
we also take children's natural language
inputs
and extract the positive sentiment based
on automatic sentiment analysis tool
similarly we extracted negative
sentiment
we also introduced something called help
sentiment which is basically the
semantic similarity
between the children's natural language
input and asking for help
lastly we also give children a mass
anxiety survey
and measure their mass anxiety before
they got started
so here um in this observation space
children's grades pre-score
and math anxiety scores are static
variables
and the rest of the variables are
affected by the actions
the rhetoric takes during the
interaction
now i'd like to talk about the action
space similar to the wizard in the last
study
the ielts children in chapel could
perform four actions
the first was guided prompt
for example the chapel says here try
thinking about the concept of volume to
solve this problem
the second is a direct hint for example
the chatbot can just send the equation
the formula of the volume to help the
kids solve the problem
the chatbot can also send an encouraging
message
and lastly sometimes the chatbot might
just acknowledge the receipt of the
message from the kid
instead instead of sending back any
meaningful feedback
here the chatbot just sends back a
smiley face
now i'd like to talk about how
the chatbot updates itself based on the
reward
i divide this into two parts during the
interaction and after the interaction
during the interaction when the child
has not yet completed the task
we used a design from thousand adults
paper published last year
um where if the reply sent by the
chatbot was a hint
we give a small positive reward to the
chatbot
and we also recorded how many hands have
been given so that
we will penalize a total number of hints
later
we also give a small positive reward
if the reply was marked as helpful by
the child
at the end of the interaction if the
child solved the task
we took children's post to
pre-improvement
and then deduct the total number of
hints children received during the
interaction
multiplied by a parameter here as a
ending reward
in this way the chatbot can learn to
give children some help
but not too much help
and if the kid created the task we give
a big penalty minus eight gear to the
chatbot
so that it will learn um how to avoid
the kid from quitting next time
um based on the parameters chosen by
passing adults paper and also our own
simulation
we chose these numbers for our hyper
parameter
in the last study our learning app was
implemented on a tablet
because of kovit this last year we
couldn't actually
invite kids to our lab so we did a
migration here
we migrated our app from the tablet to a
desktop
as a web learning app
similarly for the control system we did
the migration
as we can see here the difference looks
like this looks the same
we just changed the platform
so for the user study we performed a
large scale online study
where 339 grid three to five kids
participated
70 were assigned to the control
condition and the 269 to the aria chapel
condition
we let our iotable perform batch update
after every five kids
these 339 children were balanced in
terms of grade
in terms of gender and grade and
gender and grid were well balanced
across the two conditions
so what is the takeaway from this study
did we observe the same
performance first i found that children
who learned with a chatbot
yielded higher learning gains than
children learned who learned with a
control
i also set mandated children based on
their trial knowledge
and i found that children with nowhere
little prior knowledge
benefited much more by interacting with
the chatbot
here with the effects size of 1.1
children who came in with moderate to
high prior knowledge
still benefited by interacting with the
chatbot
just the effect size being smaller here
0.3
next for the engagement i found that
children who learned with a chatbot were
much more engaged than children who
learned with a control
similarly i performed the segmentation
and found that children with little were
no prior knowledge
were much more engaged when interacting
with the chatbot
with a large effect size 1.6 here
for children who had more prior
knowledge they still enjoy the chatbot
more
just with a smaller effect size point
two here
because our iot about can improve over
time
i also applaud children's improvement
over time
and compare that to the static control
as we can see here
although fluctuating a lot ir travel
actually yielded higher improvement for
students as shown
as as shown by the triple lines here and
then the steady control
control show in the dash green line here
over time
um then i plotted the reward of the io
agent
and as we can see here it's very likely
that our agent has not yet converged
so if we could um run the study with
more kids
the ir agent could probably convert to
better results
and yield a better learning and
engagement for children
i also found that there exists strong
correlation between children's pre-score
improvement and the rl reward
since our data did not come from a bad
normal distribution
i used kindle run correlation test to
evaluate the association
and i found that between children's
prescore and our reward
the correlation was significant with tom
beam minus 0.4
between children's preschool and
improvement
the talk here was minus 0.5
and lastly between reward and
improvement
we notice a positive correlation here
with job being
0.8 and this makes sense because our
reward function was designed
to maximize children's improvement so
one important takeaway from running this
large-scale online study
is that we should probably better
control the distribution of incoming
children
to make the io algorithm convert faster
to a greater result
i also plotted the ri agent's action
selection strategy over time
as you can see here on the rl agent
constantly
uh involve its action selection strategy
um to give you a sense just how well the
aria chat bot is able to achieve
after about 200 rounds of iteration i
presented here a real conversation
example
the kid here first said let's keep
thinking
the child decided to give a direct hint
then the kid replied with saying okay at
this point the chapel realized
the kid probably need a little bit more
help so the chat about
just send an indirect guide after that
the kids solved the task
the kid became excited and said we got
another one right
the chatbot smells back and then the
kids started to work on the next problem
the kid asked do you think we should
multiply or divide
very interesting instead of giving any
help
the travel actually just encouraged the
kid by saying
i think i have some ideas but i won't
spoil it just let me know if you need a
hint
so it turns out that this is a smart
teaching strategy
because the kid actually solved the
problem without any
help from the chair fall the kid
got excited again and the travel smelled
back
so to summarize by building this
automatic chat about using reinforcement
learning
and embed into a narrative learning
system
i show that narrative based learning
with ir temple
can promote student engagement and
learning outcomes
children with no order prior knowledge
especially benefited from the system
with a large effect size and children
with median to high prior knowledge
benefited with a small effect size
to summarize my thesis contribution i
designed and
built four different conversation-based
tutoring systems
using new ai techniques in different
domains for different age groups
and showed their effectiveness on
promoting learners engagement
and learning outcomes
today's learners need novel engaging and
effective methods
to cultivate their passion for learning
i show that through my ph dissertation
work the conversational tutors
may not only help engage students in
non-formal learning
but also improves educational outcomes
of those activities
to learn more about my phd work you can
visit this website listed here
and also read all the papers i published
before
all right thank you so we have maybe
time for
a couple questions either from folks on
the panelists or
from folks in the audience we will end
it
right after two um
the one question that came from the
audience
was um asking how given that the phrase
vocabulary of chat bots
is much more limited than humans how do
you make sure the chatbots aren't too
repetitive in conversation
um how to make sure chatbots are not too
repetitive
yeah that's a actually a very good
question so
we have two ways to address that uh
first we just
um so we make the design space really
large
so i actually have great designers
writing dialogues for us
so that's the first way uh the second so
i just want to point out that the system
we had our research prototypes
and the user studies are usually rather
short within a week
um so we ensure that users you know had
access to
different conversations in that week but
if we
run the user study longer or um you know
use the chatbot more like a real world
application i do think uh
you know people will find it a little
bit boring
limited so that's a probably the
difference between
my proof of concept system and a
real-world chatbot application
now i have a question um congratulations
on having you know large numbers of
participants in your
studies and also not just recruiting
them from
stanford and palo alto that's a good
idea to get
a more diverse population
i wonder how representative they are did
you include
students with you know low socioeconomic
backgrounds and you know more
difficulties learning
um at you know a representative level
or um where um yeah in general how
representative are these students
yeah that's a very good question so um i
have to admit that in the first study
the lab study
because children had to come to our lab
most of them were from the bay area
so the it's probably less represented
but for the second
large-scale online study because we
could um you know recruit children all
over the united states
we actually carefully control their uh
you know say household income you know
location and
even you know ethnicity groups so that
they are well represented
um yeah we we do have the you know the
household income
i think that's um kind of you know
similar to the overall household income
distribution in the united states
if that answers the question and also we
um
we plot children's prior knowledge and
we noticed that although
a lot of them were in the same grade and
of same age
the prior prior score you know very loud
so probably indicating that we have a
representative sample of children
all right well then given that we're
after two o'clock i will end the
recording here let's all thank sherry
one more time
you